from the zora to the reto to the
mountainous rock-eating gowron's The
Legend of Zelda is full of different
races and people groups all with fully
fleshed-out backstories and significance
to the world around them it's one of the
reasons why these games are so beloved
and captivating to delve into and for
the last three years breadth of the
wilds release has spiked interests in
Zelda across the entire gaming community
which is awesome with talk of the
sheikah Gerudo and the mysterious zone
AI tribe at an all-time high it's easy
for some to forget about one of the most
mysterious people groups ever to grace a
video game especially for those whose
first zelda game was breath of the wild
the race of people with the most
shrouded background that may be
connected with the fearsome Gerudo tribe
is none other than the Twilight from
Twilight Princess as we delve into the
origins of the Twilight in a partially
historical and partially theoretical
video which I find myself doing more
often recently I'm humbled to present my
friend and fellow Zelda youtuber the
Hyrule gamer who'll be helping out with
this one hey guys hyrule gamer here and
i just want to see how honored and its
site as i am to be back on your boy mass
nintendo banned his channel for another
video don't forget to check out the
partner theory to this video that's live
right now over on his channel featuring
yours truly and by the way as always
with Theory videos please be expecting
possible spoilers for multiple Zelda
games but with that out of the way
without further ado allow us to humbly
present the fate of the twili
[Music]
you
[Music]
in the game all Carina of time what you
may or may not be familiar with the game
ends a couple of different ways
there's the adult ending which takes
place when adult link defeats Ganon and
seals him away in the future and the
child ending which takes place when that
same link travels back in time to regain
his lost years he is then shown to
immediately go to see the Princess Zelda
who I'm sure he had several topics of
discussion to go over with you know like
saving the world our hopping back and
forth for a time by way of a magical
ocarina but fast forward into the next
game in the series no the next next one
tells us something about what happened
after the credits rolled in ocarina of
time the Gerudo King Ganondorf was
sentenced to death sometime between the
events of the two games the most likely
reason for Ganondorf Steff sentence
would be the Link and Zelda were able to
somehow convince the king of Hyrule of
ganondorf's ill intend although this
hasn't been officially confirmed
anywhere but either way ganondorf's true
intentions where is supposed to the
hylians
and without wasting time he was subdued
and brought to justice however when the
sages followed through web ganondorf's
execution he was able to survive his
impaling blew by the power of the
Triforce within him and actually break
free to kill one of the sages the sage
of water
the remaining sages acting quickly
decided unanimously to exile Ganondorf
to the realm of Twilight and definitely
taking the sword of six sages with him
but less it pause right there for a
second and answer a couple of questions
about this whole situation such as the
site where Ganondorf was banished from
and how this cursed location came to be
Ganondorf was banished at the peak of
arbiters grounds which is a giant
Coliseum like prison built to hold high
rules cruelest enemies or so that's what
the highly and history books say
actually I made an interesting theory
the other day that ties in very well to
this one regarding the Arbutus grounds
feel free to check that out via the link
in the description below or the card on
the top right of the screen if you want
to dive deep into the origins of this
creepy prison in a nutshell though the
arbiters grounds which is located in the
Gerudo desert by no simple coincidence
was built on top of or around the
ancient spirit temple of the Gerudo
tribe there is much evidence to support
this that I go into more so in the video
I've just mentioned but the reasoning
behind its construction is perhaps
darker than one would expect and this is
where we delve into more speculation
than fact in the years to come following
the events of Ocarina of Time speaking
from the child timeline perspective
since Ganondorf the leader and king of
the Gerudo people was revealed to be an
evil spawn of demises hatred toward the
goddesses the Gerudo were most likely
seen as enemies by the hylians and
either after a war or simply under
decree of the royal family were
imprisoned in the very same arbiters
grounds dungeon we see in-game it's
important to note that the arbiters
ground seems to favor highly in Brick
Lane construction as opposed to the
concrete or rock favouring Gerudo
construction which aids the theory as it
implies that the hylians purpose in
constructing a large prison on or around
Gerudo holy ground would most likely
mean contact with the Gerudo people the
Gerudo were then banished to the
Twilight Realm by way of the Twilight
Mirror within the arbiters grounds as
the hylians believed this would solve
their little demise problem so okay
that's pretty crazy to speculate about
right but why were they banished and how
many of them surely not all of them were
banished right and where's the proof for
all of this we will answer those
questions in just a bit
but well there may not be much evidence
to the arbiters grants been a present
for the grid Oh besides some very minor
architectural clues the notion of the
griddle evolving into the toilet has
much more we can delve into specifically
and the character designs of Midna and
zan for those who played wily princess
to its completion one of the rewards for
completing the game besides that awesome
sense of satisfaction you get from
finishing a zelda game is that you get
to see the real humanoid form of the
little imp that's been flying by your
side for the entire game witness actual
form is tall beautiful and bears some
striking similarities to the gorilla
race the most obvious the point out
would be the color of her hair and eyes
which of course have been visible for
the entire game previously but something
of
her true form brings them to light even
more her fiery red hair is the most
obvious similarity to the Gerudo tribe
as their race of predominantly women
features predominantly red hair as well
as the red eyes which are a very similar
shade to ganondorf's eyes her or mental
forehead jewelry is also similar to that
of griddle royalty most nobly seen been
born by the griddle King Ganondorf her
clothing is also strikingly similar to
the clothes and sashes that are worn by
garuda women as seen in ocarina of time
and breath of the wild but the real
striking proof as evidenced by Zant Zant
the would-be King of the Twilight people
has some admittedly pretty interesting
fashion decisions and while his
appearance may not be as strikingly
similar to the Gerudo people as mid
nazies the symbol on the front of his
clothing bears incredibly strong
resemblances to the Gerudo crest as you
can see it's not an exact copy of the
garuda crest but it's more similar to
the Gerudo symbol than any other emblem
across all of the games trust me I
checked it's entirely possible and
plausible that the Gerudo people who
were stripped of their previous
identities and who have now become the
Twilight also evolved their crest as the
years went by now of course this is
attention grabbing and may even be
convincing by this point but there's one
glaring point against this entire theory
that threatens to shut it all down enter
the interlopers the interlopers who were
never actually seen in-game but rather
just simply represented in a dreamlike
vision by dark ladies were banished to
the Twilight Realm for wielding magic
that defied the goddesses and are also
credited with being called the people of
Midna as Ganondorf seems to imply him
dis cutscene now since we know not all
of the garuda were banished to the
Twilight Realm since the Gerudo
obviously make a huge appearance in the
future game breath of the wild I present
to you this idea what if the interlopers
were members of the Garuda faction who
were banished to the Twilight for their
arrogance against the goddesses and
these dark magic wielding Gerudo were
the ones that the arbiters grounds was
actually built to house until their
banishment we already know that some of
the
practice dark magic as evidenced by two
witches from ocarina of time and even
the wizard agony who by the way has a
pale bluish complexion to his skin
what if the interlopers were garuda
witches or wizards who were banished for
their transgressions that would explain
why the Twilight bears such striking
resemblances to the Garuda with their
clothing and symbolism while also
explaining why they're still around to
make their huge appearance in breath of
the wild furthermore Midna states in
game that the twili is true king the one
who reigned before she and Xan had their
spa was lost due to greed this could
absolutely be a reference to Ganondorf
the king of the Gerudo who was obsessed
with his greed for the Triforce and
consequently stripped of honor and
sentenced to execution Xan also worships
Ganondorf as a god which is explained in
ocarina of time by speaking to a gossip
stone to be something that is his most
devout good riddle followers did as well
so let's see if we combined that the
hylians constructed the arbiters grounds
the design choices of the Twilight the
interlopers shrouded identities the
Garuda's dark magic the history of their
fallen king and their worship of
Ganondorf the evidence seems to point to
the Twilight being at least partially of
Garuda origin but after the credits roll
then pause and show Midna returning to
Twilight just before shower in the
mirror for goods then keep rolling what
happened to the twili princess zelda
makes a comment in breath of the wild
that alludes to the knowledgeable
existence of the Twilight Realm
meaning the Twilight are still out there
somewhere in a world shrouded in
Twilight you can't help but ask the
obvious question could we be seeing
their return and what would this mean
for the present-day Gerudo is Midna
still alive if you'd like answers to
these questions make like Midna and flip
to the other side of this coin just
don't shatter the mirror come back here
afterwards check us out in hi ROH gamers
alternate theory over on his channel
featuring yours truly live or right now
and also let us know what you think of
our theories in the comments below
hey guys thank you so much for watching
as always it was an absolute pleasure to
work with you again mr. hyrule gamer
again thank you all
so much for having me it's been a blast
to work with Banda again and be sure to
go check out the video we did over my
channel covering the possibility of the
Twilight Realm ever returning to the
Zelda series huge thank you as always to
my fantastic patrons who I wouldn't be
able to do any of this without if you're
interested in getting your name up here
at the end of each my videos and some
exclusive perks coming soon follow the
link in the description below to find
out how also down there are links to my
social media pages so come on over and
say hi to me what are you waiting for
remember to like this video if you
enjoyed watching and subscribe for much
more Nintendo content to come that's all
I've got for you in this one so as
always I hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day
this is masks antenna bandits signing
out peace
[Music]